[Music]
jaws made him scary the mag made him big
and NATO made him blow but in 1999 the
same shark movie again every five years
came with a twist
the Sharks are smart and this movie is
dumb nasty-looking
deep blue sea suit up for the ultimate
b-movie okay second ultimate movie and
journey under the sea to a lab built for
one purpose to trap its employees
underwater the elevator seals off
automatically to keep the shaft in
facility there's no way off thanks to
flooded hopeless thinking and also to
cure Alzheimer's by sucking out the
brains of unconscious super sharks as a
side-effect the shots got smarter okay
sure whatever in this poor man's ripoff
of Jurassic Park welcome to a quieter
welcome to Jurassic complete with
approaching tropical storm running on a
skeleton crew on their most important
weekend
Sam Jackson hiding in a kitchen scene
and guy who gets eaten for resetting the
power but instead at the iconic John
Williams score LL Cool J gets to rap
about how his hat is like a shark's fin
it isn't though go down under with the
shadiest group of shark snacks since
boys night on the Orca
whether it's the mysterious badass with
a past I don't make ways I mean the
terms of my parole
the former preacher with a past I have
looked Pope and I've loved the bottle
the head scientist with a past we
violated the Harvard contract or the CEO
with the past seven of us survived the
slide and only five made it out but in
his case that past never involved asking
what he spent billions and billions of
dollars on so treat me like a tourist
Wow just what the hell did you do those
shots somebody please tell me what that
is well that's a fair question actually
it stellan skarsgård attached to a
gurney about to turn your lab window
into skarsgård shark charts well trust
him that five times fast scores go shark
charts car car shark charts her score
garsh cards I forget it strap in for the
only Christian shark movie you need to
see or even knew existed where God's
vengeful creatures attacked teenagers
for premarital sex and drinking punish
evil scientist for defying the natural
order why God's creation is power and
one of the only two to make it out alive
is named preacher nice
maybe I'm just reading into things but
help me out here wouldn't you rather
watch deep blue sea and Sunday School
then sing father Abraham a thousand
times can I get an amen
so get ready to stare ominously out of
porthole
[Music]
react to tremors like the original cast
of Star Trek
and get absolutely drenched over and
over and over again
for a fill with just enough shark
schlock to prove that the only thing
harder than making a good shark movie is
making a good bad shark movie never
thought I'd say this but
sharknado kinda had the right idea
[Applause]
starring the punished shark I've had it
with these monkey fighting sharks in
this Monday to Friday lab sitting on the
dot with Cool J ah Polly want a wrapper
Michael Rapaport as himself who do you
trust trust me she smart see sharks on
the seafloor ocean water I guess is what
they were going for and all these oh ma
jizz - jaws
[Music]
[Applause]
the shark tank redemption you know I'm
usually against needless sequels but
this is a prequel to a street sharks
movie I am so on board and so it's been
diesel a thousand years ago this land
was green and good until the crystal
cracked dude you're embarrassing me in
front of the Wizards I kick ass for the
Lord now available to own on video
cassette Wicky wild well Wicky Wicky
wild Wicky wild Wicky Wicky wild wild
wild west